G
IN HOLLYWOOD RIGHT NOW TO
SILENCE HIM AND CONSERVATIVES.
>> BUT FIRST, BACKLASH BUILDING
TONIGHT OVER PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
END OF THE WORD -- WORLD
RHETORIC ABOUT PUTIN USING
NUCLEAR WEAPONS AFTER HE RAN
FROM REPORTERS WHO ASKED ABOUT
IT.
HE MADE THESE COMMENTS OFF
CAMERA EARLIER THIS WEEK.
QUOTE: THINK ABOUT IT, WE HAVE
NOT FACED THE PROSPECT OF
ARMAGEDDON SINCE KENNEDY AND THE
CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS.
HE WENT ON TO SAY HE IS NOT
JOKING WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT
POTENTIAL USE OF TACTICAL AND
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THEN YESTERDAY HE WENT AFTER
PUTIN AGAIN, THIS TIME OVER HIGH
GAS PRICES IN AN A AWKWARD
SPEECH ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
>> LET ME START OFF WITH TWO
WORDS, MADE IN AMERICA.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
MADE IN AMERICA.
THAT'S NOT HYPERBOLE, I'M NOT
JOKING ABOUT THAT, AS YOU KNOW.
I WAS ABLE TO BRING GASOLINE
DOWN WELL OVER $1.60, BUT IT'S
INCHING UP BECAUSE OF WHAT THE
RUSSIANS AND THE SAUDIS JUST
DID.
I'M NOT FINISHED WITH THAT YET.
>> HE JUST TAPPED INTO THE
STRATEGIC OIL RESERVE, AGAIN
DEPLETING IT TO A 40-YEAR LOW
AFTER O PECK PLUS -- OPEC+
DECIDED TO CUT PRODUCTION.
>> THE IDEA THAT SAUDI ARABIA
WOULD DO THIS TO HARM THE U.S.
IS ABSOLUTELY NOT CORRECT AT
ALL.
WITH DUE RESPECT, THE REASON YOU
HAVE HIGH PRICES IN THE UNITED
STATES IS BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE
REFINING SHORTAGE THAT HAS BEEN
IN EXISTENCE FOR MORE THAN 20
YEARS.
YOU HAVEN'T BUILT REFINERIES IN
DECADES.
IT'S AS A ARE RESULT OF THE
SHORTAGE OF REFINING CAPACITY
THAT YOU HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
GASOLINE AND AN INCREASE IN THE
PRICE OF GASOLINE.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
FUNDAMENTALS OF CRUDE OR SUPPLY
AND NAMED.
>> SO, LISTEN, I THINK THAT'S A
FASCINATING COMMENT, AND I WANT
TO GET TO JOE BIDEN IN A SECOND.
JACKIE, YOU'RE LINE OUR RESIDENT
ENERGY EXPERT --
[LAUGHTER]
SO HERE YOU HAVE THE SAUDIS
SAYING THE THE ISSUE WITH
AMERICAN GAS PRICES IS YOU HAD A
DECLINE IN REFINING CAPACITY,
BUT OVER THE PAST COUPLE YEARS
OUR REFINING HASN'T GONE DOWN,
OUR OIL PRODUCTION HAS GONE
DOWN.
>> IT ABSOLUTELY HAS.
REMEMBER, THE OIL BOOM IS
RELATIVELY NEW.
PRESIDENT TRUMP COMES INTO
OFFICE, HE MAKES US THE WORLD'S
NUMBER ONE OIL PRODUCER,
SOMETHING WE NEVER THOUGHT WE
WOULD SEE IN OUR LIFETIME.
ELECTION IS IN NOVEMBER OF 2016.
DECEMBER OF 2016, SEAN, THAT'S
WHEN RUSSIA DECIDES WE'RE GOING
TO JOIN WITH SAUDI ARABIA, AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE A PART OF WHAT
WE CALL OPEC+.
INTERESTING?
NOT REALLY.
PUTIN'S SITTING BACK, HE'S
WATCHING THE DYNAMIC, HE SEES
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND HE SAYS HE
IS GOING TO EXPAND CAPACITY, AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BECOME NUMBER
ONE.
WHAT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED?
WE WOULD HAVE BUILT MORE
REFINERIES TO KEEP THE BOOM
GOING.
THEN YOU HAD PRESIDENT BIDEN
COME IN AND SAY I'M GOING TO
ATTACK OIL AND GAS.
NO OIL COMPANY WANTS TO BUILD A
REFINERY OR ANYTHING ELSE, AND
THEY STOP INVESTING.
WHAT'S REALLY INTERESTING HERE
IS THE RUSSIA/SAUDI ALLIANCE.
I AGREE WITH THE MINISTER, I
DON'T THINK THEY'RE TRYING TO --
I DON'T THINK THE SAUDIS ARE
TRYING TO HARM US, PER SE, BUT
THIS IS A BUSINESS, AND IT'S
ABOUT SUPPLY AND DEMAND, IT'S
ABOUT PRICING.
RUSSIA'S IN A TOUGH SPOT RIGHT
NOW.
IT NEEDS THESE PRICES TO STAY U-
>> I ASK YOU A QUESTION ABOUT
THAT --
>> -- AND HERE WE ARE.
>> THE SAUDIS DON'T LIKE JOE
BIDEN, THE RUSSIANS DON'T LIKE
HIM, PUTIN DOESN'T LIKE HIM.
SO ISN'T IT FAIR TO SAY WE KNOW
THIS IS BAD IN THE U.S., LET'S
CUT PRODUCTION BY 2 MILLION
BARRELS A DAY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND THEY NEVER PROMISED THAT
THEY WOULDN'T DO THAT OR THAT
THEY WERE WORRIED ABOUT OUR GAS
PRICES.
QUITE FRANKLY, THEY RUN THEIR
WHOLE KINGDOM CAN ON OIL
REVENUE.
WHEN PRICES ARE HIGH, IT'S A
GREAT THING FOR THEM.
PUTIN NEEDS PRICES HIGH TOO.
WE'RE THE ONES SUFFERING.
>> GIANNO, WHAT DOES THIS SAY
ABOUT JOE BIDEN HE'S TALKING
ABOUT, TWO WORDS, MADE IN
AMERICA -- MY COUNT, THAT'S
THREE WORDS, HOW DUMB IS THAT?
[LAUGHTER]
WE HAVE ALL THIS ENERGY IN
AMERICA, AND HERE HE IS GOING TO
PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY HATE US,
AND HE'S BEGGING THEM TO PRODUCE
MORE OIL WHEN HERE AT HOME HE'S
DOING THE SAME THING THE SAUDIS
ARE DOING, CUTTING PRODUCTION BY
WAY OF POLICIES?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND JOE BIDEN HAS BECOME THE KID
WHO CRIED WOLF, AND INSTEAD OF
WOLF, IT'S PUTIN, PUTIN, PUTIN.
HE'S FAILING THE LEADERSHIP TEST
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
MAJOR ISSUE THAT IMPACTS MOST
AMERICANS.
NOT JUST THE PRICE OF OIL, BUT
DEALING WITH WORLD LEADERS, THEY
LOST RESPECT FOR US.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE WHAT WE SAY
ANYMORE.
THIS STATEMENT THAT JOE BIDEN
JUST MADE TELLS US ALL OF THAT
WHEN THE WHITE HOUSE CONTINUES
TO WALK BACK THE STATEMENTS THAT
HE MAKES.
WE DON'T HAVE A LEADER IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WE HAVE A GUY THAT'S IN A SUIT,
AN EMPTY SUIT, IS WHAT I WOULD
CALL IT.
57% OF AMERICANS SAY IN THE LAST
SIX MONTHS THE ACTIONS OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE
NEGATIVELY I IMPACTED THEIR
LIVES ON ISSUES OF CONCERN TO
THEM, INCLUDING GAS PRICES,
INFLATION, THE BORDER, JOBS.
WE'RE IN A TERRIBLE THE
SITUATION RIGHT NOW.
WE DON'T HAVE SOMEBODY THAT'S
GOING TO LEAD US TO VICTORY,
WE'VE GOT SOMEBODY THAT
AMERICANS ARE DOUBTING HIS
MENTAL CAPACITY.
SO SOMETHING NEEDS TO CHANGE
RIGHT AWAY, AND THIS ISN'T THE
GUY, SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO.
>> AND WHAT'S SHAMEFUL IS THAT
THE PRESS IN THE LAST ELECTION
WAS, LIKE, WE NEED AN ADULT IN
THE ROOM.
WE WANT TO BRING THE ADULT BACK,
AND THIS IS WHAT YOU GET WITH
JOE BIDEN.
IT'S A CLOWN SHOW.
LARA, NIKKI HALEY, FORMER
AMBASSADOR TO THE U.N., SAYSES
BIDEN'S RHETORIC INVOKES FEAR
UNNECESSARILY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> EVERY TIME HE SPEAKS IT'S
JUST UNPRODUCTIVE BECAUSE ON ONE
SIDE YOU'RE PUTTING FEAR IN
AMERICANS, WHICH IS NOT HELPFUL,
AND IT REALLY QUESTIONS HIS
LEADERSHIP.
ON OTHER SIDE, IF HE KNOWS PUTIN
SO WELL, HE WOULD KNOW HE SHOULD
NOT BE SAYING THIS IS ARMAGEDDON
BECAUSE PUTIN IS HEARING THAT.
WHAT HE NEEDS TO DO IS HAVE
DETERRENTS.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS IN
OFFICE, YOU DIDN'T SEE THESE
DICTATORS DOING THIS BECAUSE
THERE WASN'T THE WEAKNESS THAT
WE'RE SEEING TODAY.
>> LARA, IS SHE RIGHT?
>> SHE'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
YOU DID NOT SEE ANY NEW WARS
STARTED UNDER MY FATHER-IN-LAW'S
ADMINISTRATION.
IT WAS PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH.
PEOPLE RESPECTED DONALD TRUMP
BECAUSE HE EXUDED STRENGTH.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN WANT TO TRY THE
IT.
I ACTUALLY INTERVIEW ISED MY
FATHER-IN-LAW IF RECENTLY ON A
PODCAST I HAVE CALLED THE RIGHT
VIEW -- KNOCK ON "THE VIEW," --
[LAUGHTER]
AND I ASKED HIM ABOUT THIS.
I SAID, WHAT WOULD YOU DO IF YOU
WERE IN THIS SITUATION RIGHT NOW
WITH RUSSIA AND UKRAINE?
HOW DO YOU GET OUT OF THIS?
WHAT DO WE DO AT THIS POINT?
HE SAID, FIRST OF ALL, THIS
WOULD HAVE NEVER HAPPENED --
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> -- WHETHER WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT GREEN LIGHTING THE NORD
STREAM NORD STREAM 2 PIPELINE,
CUTTING OFF -- JACKIE, AS YOU
JUST TALKED ABOUT, AMERICA'S
ENERGY LEADERSHIP AROUND THE
WORLD AND OUR EXPORTATION.
BUT HE SAID AT THIS POINT YOU
HAVE TO MAKE A DEAL.
AT THIS POINT BETWEEN RUSSIA AND
UKRAINE, THERE SHOULD BE
SOMEBODY TRYING TO MAKE A DEAL.
THE EUROPEANS HAVE TO COME
TOGETHER AND SOMETHING HAS TO
HAPPEN BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
CONTINUE DOWN THIS PATH.
AND MY QUESTION IS WHY HAVEN'T
WE HEARD ANY MOVEMENT ON THAT
FRONT FROM JOE BIDEN, FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE?
NO ONE IS TALKING ABOUT HOW TO
END THIS WAR MANY UKRAINE, HOW
TO ACTUALLY GET OUT OF THIS.
AND IT'S HEADED DOWN A REALLY
SCARY PATH, I THINK, RIGHT NOW
FOR A LOT OF US.
>> INSTEAD, WE KEEP JUST SENDING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN AID TO
KEEP IT GOING LONGER AND LONGER.
AND DO YOU THINK PUTIN.
'S GOING TO HELP US WITH OIL
WHEN WE'RE FIGHTING A PROXY WAR
AND FUNDING IT?
>> I THINK A LOT OF US SAW
RUSSIA INVADE ANOTHER COUNTRY,
UKRAINE, AND WE'RE LIKE, LISTEN,
WE WANT TO DE.
FEND THOSE WHO WERE INVADED.
AND I THINK A LOT OF AMERICANS
WERE IN FAVOR OF THIS.
BUT NOW WE STEP BACK AND GO,
WE'RE AT THE BRINK OF
ARMAGEDDON?
NUCLEAR WAR?
HOW FAR DO YOU WANT TO GO?
HOW FAR DO YOU WANT TO TAKE IT,
GIANNO, TO SAY WE COULD HAVE
GLOBAL DESTRUCTION IF THIS GOES
MUCH FURTHER.
YOU NEED SOMEONE TO SAY LET'S
CUT A DEAL, LET'S TALK ABOUT IT.
LET'S NOT SAY WE NEED REGIME
CHANGE IN RUSSIA.
THAT'S ONLY GOING TO BACK PUTIN
INTO A CASHER.
>> AND THAT'S PART OF THE REASON
WHY THIS MIDTERM ELECTION COMING
UP IS SO DARN IMPORTANT.
WE NEED TO HAVE AN ADULT IN THE
ROOM, WE NEED TO STOP BIDEN'S
ACTIONS BECAUSE HE'S LEADING US
INTO DESTRUCTION.
YOU CONTINUE TO POUR OUT
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO THE
UKRAINE WHEN WE NEED THE HELP
HERE.
HONESTLY, I'M ALL FOR SUPPORT OF
UKRAINE, BUT WE'VE GOT TO THINK
ABOUT OUR COUNTRY FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD DO
NOT RESPECT US ANYMORE.
WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN LONDON
AS THE U.K. AS AN EXAMPLE WHEN
THE PARLIAMENT WAS SAYING, HEY,
WE DON'T -- THERE'S NO LEADER IN
AMERICA ANYMORE.
THIS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE.
AND BIDEN IS SIMPLY NOT UP FOR
THE JOB.
WE CONTINUE TO SEE THAT TIME AND
TIME AGAIN.
AND THE REAL ISSUE HERE IS RIGHT
HERE AT HOME, THE PRESS WON'T
HOLD HIM ACCOUNTABLE.
WHY IS THAT?
IF TRUMP WAS DOING THIS KIND OF
STUFF, THEY WOULD BE SAYING WE
NEED A THIRD IMPEACHMENT,
HONESTLY.
>> 100%.
YOU HAVE JOE BIDEN MAKING THESE
OFFHANDED COMMENTS THAT ARE
ELEVATING THE TEMPERATURE, BUT
HE COULD DO THINGS THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY PUT PRESSURE ON RUSSIA
WITHOUT ACTUALLY SAYING IT WHICH
IS AMERICAN OIL AND GAS.
LISTEN TO WHAT LARRY SUMMERS HAD
TO SAY ABOUT THE BIDEN POLICY ON
OIL.
>> LOOK, WE MADE A MISTAKE BY
CANCELING THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE.
WE MADE A MISTAKE BY SLOWING
DOWN ALL KINDS OF PERMITTING
ACTIVITY.
WE MADE A MISTAKE BY BEING
HOSTILE AS A COUNTRY TO NATURAL
GAS.
>> LARA, THIS IS NOT A
RIGHT-WING CONSERVATIVE, THIS IS
THE FORMER ECONOMIC ADVISER TO
BARACK OBAMA SAYING THESE THINGS
ABOUT JOE BIDEN'S POLICIES.
>> BUT IT'S OBVIOUS.
IT'S OBVIOUS TO ANYONE WHO IS
PAYING ATTENTION IN ANY SORT OF
WAY WHAT IS BOEING ON HERE.
THE REASON THAT WE HAVE HIGH
INFLATION, THE REASON THAT WE
ARE IN THIS SITUATION, THE
REASON, QUITE FRANKLY, THAT
RUSSIA HAD THE FUNDING TO GO IN
AND START THIS WAR IN UKRAINE,
IT ALL BOILS DOWN TO JOE BIDEN
AND HIS BAD POLICIES FROM DAY
ONE IN OFFICE CAB SELLING THE
KEYSTONE PIPELINE. -- CANCELING.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S WHERE IT STARTS AND
THEN IT IS A SNOWBALL EFFECT.
YOU SEE INFLATION GOING UP
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS ARE JUST
DUMPING MONEY OUT AS FAST AS
THEY POSSIBLY CAN.
WITH THE HIGH GAS PRICES,
THERE'S NO END IN SIGHT.
LARRY SUMMERS IS RIGHT, YOU
KNOW?
AND THIS IS NO, YOU KNOW,
RIGHT-LEANING CONSPIRACY
THEORIST BY MY MEASURE.
>> SOMEONE WHO JUST BELIEVES IN
GOOD POLICY AND UNDERSTANDS THAT
JOE BIDEN IS HITTING THE AVERAGE
DAY, EVERY MIDDLE CLASS AMERICAN
FAMILY WITH TH